[Music]
hello everyone
in the previous video we have uh
obtained these two relationships
connecting the
derivatives with respect to x and y
uh to those uh derivatives to those uh
the derivatives uh with respect to s and
n and we are going to utilize these
relations
uh in the in the equation which we had
obtained in the in the video previous to
this
uh previous to the last one so we are
going to use these relationships
back uh in the
like in the previous page so that was in
the in the video
uh previous to the last one so here so
what i'll do is i'll just copy this
equation
and start working on this
utilizing the relations which i had
obtained in the previous video
so let me go to the new page
paste it here and i'll start working
from here
so what i'll do is
uh first of all i will collect
uh the terms which have uh
the del del x terms common so
this term i will i'll take this term
together with uh with this term because
both of them have the del delta w del x
uh and i will consider this term
together with this term
all right i'll also make a couple of
other modifications
in the next step uh i will
i'll remove this subscript s from
all these integration terms which are
basically cyclic integral cyclic line
integrals
over the entire contour of our domain
because i'm going to use the s
and n coordinate system variables uh
there might be a little bit of a
confusion about which s is what
and so on furthermore i will write
this term uh which is not going to
change
the subsequent steps first so
let me um start today's work
uh
i'll just write this as it is d delta 4
w minus q
delta w d a
and then uh
this term this mx
nx plus this one
mxy y
outside i have del delta w
del x and the integration is with
respect to
s next i will have
in a similar fashion combining this term
and this term
mxy nx
plus m y
n y
del delta w del y
d s and finally i am going to take this
term together with
this term plus
qx nx plus
u y and y
delta w e s this whole thing
is equal to zero now the next thing that
i need to do
is to replace this del del x term
with what i had obtained in the previous
video
so
basically these relations so obviously
the terms are going to become
slightly long uh but no matter we'll do
the work
so i'll just copy this thing from here
i'll utilize that a little bit later uh
first
i just copy this term also
together with up to here
and this del delta w del x term that
i'll just
utilize from here so all that i need to
do
is write this as minus n y
del delta w
del s plus
n x del delta w
del n
all right i can ease this out
next uh i'll
i'll write this term sorry
i'll write this term
and now i have to replace this
del del y term with what i had obtained
in the previous video
so again copy that out
of course i'll have to write the delta w
terms
[Music]
okay
and then i'll have these terms which
remain
unchanged
okay next
up
what i'll do is uh i really have to do
this
uh this expanding it out
but i'll do this
so so the plan is like this for the next
step i'm going
to multiply all of this out okay
but at the same time i will collect all
the terms
which have as their coefficient this
del del ester okay so the del delta w
del s term
that i will take is common and
similarly i'll take all the terms having
del delta w del
n as common so i'm skipping a step here
but i hope it's all right so
let me just try to write this down
quickly
the first term remains as it is
so maybe it's uh it's a better idea if i
i don't do this here uh
instead i just i just copy this thing
out
and go to the next page
there's no point in cluttering it out
[Music]
okay that remains the same
next i'll multiply this out
that gives me minus mx
nx and y
minus m xy
and y squared
and i'll next consider these terms which
have
this del delta s term so that is m x y
n x square with a minus
and then this this term
minus my of course i have to be a little
bit careful here
i already have a minus outside outside
here
so i need to write this with a plus
so this is plus m y
n x and y
all right
i have that
okay
ah i don't need the square bracket
actually
next i'm going to consider
the terms which will have the del delta
n
terms so going here
what i'll have is
mx and x square
plus m x y
and x and y from here
then plus m
x y
again n x and y so this is basically a
twice of that term
plus m y in y square
delta w del n
of course i've missed this ts term over
here
write that and finally this last term
involving the cues that remains
unchanged
okay now
so this is the part of where
i pull off a little bit of a stunt
okay the stunt is in this form that this
entire
term uh this entire thing
that i will uh i will write
as uh as another term of
mns and this entire thing within the
first bracket
that i will write as mn and i'll have a
little discussion about it
but let me first write down what i
what i want here please note that
these are over the entire domains
for the entire domain uh
this thing that i will
that i'm writing as mns
del delta w del s
yes and this entire thing
that i'm writing as m
n
furthermore this last term q x n x plus
q
y and y that i am writing as
u n
delta w ts equal to 0
so what has what has gone on here you
see
uh let me just write that properly that
where i'm using
mns is equal to
so this is m x minus
m y if you look carefully here
uh i'm taking n x and y common plus
m x y and x square
minus n y square
okay and
m n that is just
m x and x square
plus m x y twice m x y
and x and y so i've combined this with
this
plus m y and y square
okay so what what are these two
relations why am i writing like that
so you see even though these terms this
mx and xy
uh my the they are
the moments but they are defined if you
remember
if you go back to the previous slides uh
you will see that they are defined in
terms of
the stresses so they are basically
this is coming from the sigma x um z
dz integration from minus h by 2 to h by
2.
similarly this is coming from the sigma
yy term and this
mxy is coming from the sigma xy term
now uh all of these relation these two
relations that i have written
uh you can interpret that as
coming from an equivalent relationship
between the sigma ns and the sigma x
sigma y and sigma xy
and here sigma n with uh
as as it is connected to sigma xx sigma
yy and sigma xy and what are those two
relationships
to sigma n and the sigma nx ns
so it may seem a little bit alien to you
written in this particular form
uh in terms of this n and s variable
very general mathematical looking but i
assure you that
all of you who have undergone
undergraduate mechanics of solids
have actually come across this
relationships not in terms of these
moments
but in but they but but the the
relationships
that i just alluded to uh
regarding the connections between the
stresses
that you have all come across in your
undergraduate mechanics of solids
so you think about it a little bit so if
you remember
what you did back when learning uh
transformation of stresses in two
dimensions
so you considered with respect to a x
y coordinate system stresses like sigma
x x
sigma y y and sigma x y and then you
went on
to obtain the relationship
or stress components in another rotated
coordinate system
which was the x dash y dash coordinate
system
and there you had sigma x dash x dash
sigma y dash y dash
and sigma x dash y dash and uh and you
found out a relationship
between those dashed variables the
dashed components of stresses with the
non-dash components of stresses
using the cos theta sine theta and so on
in fact
those were very important relationships
as far as your objective
questions were uh concerned so you all
know about that
and you can see that there is a direct
connection between that
if you just replace this nx by cos theta
and this
n y by sine theta so that is why i am
saying that all of you are actually
familiar with this thing this is not
something
really new okay so once you are
convinced with this
uh but no matter i mean just to just to
refresh your memory
uh i will give the
these and this this connection by
establishing this connection again as an
as a little exercise uh in the problem
sheet associated with the classical
plate theory
so that will be problem sheet number
three uh
so students who are enrolled in this
advanced mechanics of solids course
will be able to do it and maybe ask
their doubts during the live sessions
anyway so let me proceed here uh what do
we what do we do after this
you see after we have obtained this
there is a little bit of
nothing that we can do to simplify this
especially with regards
to this particular term the term which
is
involving the del del s
so now what i'll do is i'll copy this
thing out
go to the new page
and focus my attention on this term
involving this del del
s so what i want to say here is this
m s del delta w
del s d s you see this is
a line integration so
if you are considering a contour
in this fashion if you are considering a
contour in this fashion
you are actually so you may remember
that
we were considering we had considered
our our coordinate axis in this fashion
this was our x and this was our y
and our s and n were
directed in this fashion s
n so we were basically traversing this
contour
in this kind of uh tracking it like this
okay so if you if you go like that what
you're basically doing
you are starting out from a certain
point
okay you're starting out from a certain
point let that point
be let's say some point p1
okay and you are going through the
entire
set of points which make up this this
contour and then you are coming back to
this
point p1 so
[Music]
can we perhaps think
of uh doing an integration by parts
for this so what happens if we do that
so we proceed like we always proceed for
integration by parts we considered
this as our first bit and this as the
second bit
so in this boundary term
uh it is this second bit which will be
integrated
with respect to s so we'll obtain this
delta w
so this is our boundary term but please
note that for this boundary
the lower limit is p1 and the upper
limit is also p1
because this is a cyclic integral okay
and we are actually starting
from the from a point and coming back up
after traversing the whole contour to
the same point that is why the lower
limit is p1
the upper limit is also p1 which means
that this boundary term that is
basically going to be zero because no
matter what the value of this m and s
delta w
be we do not know what it is but
whatever its value is that p1 is the
same value at p1 so you are basically
subtracting the same thing
from itself okay
so what will be left with is
this kind of a term
all right so
this is going to be zero
they seem to be 0 for a closed quantity
understand that
so what happens if we substitute this
back here
we have the delta 4
w minus q that remains unchanged
for this this minus will become a plus
course with this minus
this term remains as it is
and this term also remains as it is
that and move that up a little bit
please note that i have not uh
explicitly discussed
uh this connection this q n
is equal to q x n x plus q y n y but
just in the same way that we have
obtained the connection between the
sigma
or the the m n the m s and the m x m y
and m x y we can obtain
a similar kind of transform relation
between the q and q x and q y are
thinking in terms
of the stresses okay
now uh
where do we go from here you please note
that our
ultimate objective just like as it was
it was in back in beam theory
our ultimate objective here is to obtain
a set of governing equations
and the corresponding boundary
conditions so
whatever simplification that we could
have done
we have done here so now it is time to
finally write down
the governing equations and boundary
conditions uh
well after this long set of derivations
uh rather long set of derivations
covering
five parts of lectures we can finally
write down the governing equation here
as
all that you have to do is pick out the
term uh which is over the entire domain
okay so this is our domain term and this
even though it is written in terms of an
integration here integration here
integration here
but these are integrations over the
boundaries okay
boundary means over this this periphery
okay so for the governing differential
equation we only need to worry about
this
or consider that uh
it's like this
and please i i i request all of you to
please make a comparison
of this equation that we have obtained
for the classical plate theory
with the equation that we had obtained
back
while considering only the bending of
beam
much earlier okay so there also we had
obtained
uh an equation which was like e i
r d 4 w d x 4 is equal to q
so you make a comparison with this
equation with that equation
okay so they are both fourth order
equations
the difference is that here we have this
d term which is the bending rigidity
and back then back there we had the e i
term
uh which was which was like the flexural
rigidity uh and
this q of course is the same thing uh
there we had
just the one fourth order derivative
term with respect to x
because that was a one dimensional
problem but this is
effectively this this classical plate
theory has enabled us
to reduce the whole problem to
effectively a two dimensional theory
even though we started out
by considering a three-dimensional
problem but by integrating
out with respect to this with respect to
the z direction
we have effectively reduces to a two
dimensional problem
uh and uh this del four the by harmonic
operator
that takes that takes into account all
the derivatives with respect to x
and y next for the boundary conditions
i have uh
either
so i'm going to consider this term now
either
del n n s del
s together with this term because you
see
that this has the coefficient of delta w
this also has the coefficient of delta w
that is equal to 0 or
[Music]
w is specified
next we consider this term and say
that either
and nn is equal to zero
or del w
del n is specified
so there is a lot of similarity with
what we had obtained back in beam theory
with what we are obtaining here uh so
just
uh to
mention the physical interpretation of
this you see that if
for example our plate is clamped
then we would know that
along the along then that periphery the
w would be
zero but more importantly w would be
specified
so for a clamp plate we'd have to
consider this
and reject this similarly
if uh if again our our
slope is given for example again if the
plate is clamped then we know that the
delta w del n
that would be zero so we have to reject
this term but if on the other hand our
plate is simply supported
then we have to consider this m n equal
to 0 which represents
the the moment
so a simply supported plate would not
have any resistance
to rotation and that would be given by
this condition
the zero moment condition all throughout
the periphery
and suppose uh a certain
portion of the periphery certain portion
of the periphery that is
not clam not simply supported or
anything uh it is just free
then you understand that the condition
the physical condition
uh there would be uh would be that
it is uh it is having a
zero shear and it is this condition okay
the zero shear conditions
present by that and of course you will
have uh
the appropriate condition from this
statement also okay
in fact you will have this mn equal to
zero because a shear
because a free part of this periphery
would not have any slope specified there
so it is this condition which would
again be applicable so
depending on the kind of problem
that we are handling would have to
choose the appropriate boundary
conditions
now this particular thing that we have
obtained here
that has a certain uh certain special
uh discussion associated with it but
we'll see
about it later so for now uh i'll
stop this video but uh as far as
problems are concerned
what we'll do is we will take up
problems a number of problems of
considering a circular plate now
when we have to specialize to the case
of
a circular plate from this general n
s coordinate system what we have to do
basically is to go from this
ns to a r theta coordinate system
okay so that entails another set of uh
transformations but uh
those are some things which are quite
familiar to you at least
if you if you directly think in terms of
going from the x y coordinate system to
the r theta coordinate system
uh you know as uh you know how to do
those transformations cursive what we
learned during applied elasticity
but uh at the same time it is still
possible
to go directly from this ns coordinate
system to the r theta coordinate system
but but we'll see about that later so
that's all for now thank you very much